sans cesse et toujours défendre son
bilan et apaiser la colère des forces de
l'ordre hier christophe castaner s'est
prêté à un numéro d'équilibriste devant
les sénateurs
une audition de la chambre haute sur les
moyens d'action et les méthodes
d'intervention de la police et de la
gendarmerie
l'occasion pour le ministre de
l'intérieur de présenter les résultats
de son action place beauvau mais surtout
de réparer le lien rompu avec ses
effectifs voilà plusieurs semaines que
les forces de l'ordre manifestent leur
mécontentement suite aux propos de leur
ministre de tutelle concernant le
racisme dans leurs rangs jeudi devant
les élus christophe castaner a voulu
recoller les morceaux
lors des dernières semaines et je dirais
même lors des derniers mois on a vu des
confusions et des amalgames des combats
et des causes nobles qui ont été
dévoyées par des militants qui ne
veulent qu'une chose c'est faire
vaciller la république comme je lé
rappeler le 8 juin dernier seuls les
policiers et les gendarmes sont fondés à
faire un usage légitime de la force
ils sont seuls à être fondés à défendre
l'ordre républicain
nous devons le défendre sans cesse face
aux amalgames et aux accusations qu'ils
subissent les défendre face aux insultes
face aux coûts les défendre face à cette
accusation siens juste de racisme ou de
violence structurelle organisée je les
10000 fois je le dis une fois de plus il
n'y a pas de police violente
il n'y a pas de police raciste un
soutien aux forces de l'ordre qui est
également passé par des annonces sur une
possibilité pour les policiers et
gendarmes de film est davantage leur
interpellation
le ministre est ensuite revenu sur les
techniques d'intervention des forces de
l'ordre
l'objet de cette audition christophe
castaner s'est défendu de tout couac de
communication à propos de la technique
dite de l'étranglement une méthode
d'interpellations très décriée notamment
depuis la mort le 3 janvier dernier de
cédric joue via suite à un contrôle de
police la famille de ce livreur de 42
ans a demandé ce mardi que
l'étranglement tout comme le placage
ventrale soit tout bonnement interdite
selon le ministre la méthode ne sera
plus enseigner aux futurs policiers
j'ai demandé à ce que soit lancé un
groupe de travail conjoint entre la
police et la gendarmerie pour passer en
revue les techniques d'interpellation
à l'issue de ces travaux et estimant la
méthode comme dangereuse le directeur
général de la police nationale m'a
proposé de sur ce
voire à l'enseignement de l'étranglement
d'ailleurs elle n'est plus enseignée
depuis le début des années 2000 dans la
gendarmerie nationale ni dans
l'administration pénitentiaire et donc
en conséquence avec laurent nunez nous
avons décidé de mettre fin à son
enseignement
nous avons également il n'y a pas eu
d'évolution ni de rétropédalage demander
un nouveau groupe de travail de faire
des propositions très vite d'ici le 1er
septembre pour trouver des alternatives
à cette méthode
je suis convaincu aussi que nous devrons
faire monter en puissance la formation
continue des policiers et gendarmes sur
la voie publique et c'est pourquoi j'ai
décidé que les policiers et gendarmes
devraient désormais suivre un nombre
d'heures annuel minimal de formation aux
techniques d'intervention sans quoi il
ne pourrait plus exercer sur la voie
publique
reste à savoir si ces annonces seront
suffisantes pour assurer à la fois les
forces de l'ordre et les manifestants
anti violence policière
christophe castaner joue gros les
rumeurs de remaniement vont bon train et
le ministre est plus que jamais sur la
sellette